[Music]
good morning and welcome to the global
progressive forum
you just came out of a negotiation what
was it on we were talking about the very
relevant uh privacy regulation myrtle
bitboy is the winner of this special
award time pictures that represent the
covet crisis that we've been through i'm
gonna head back now to the main studio
ladies can you hear me take it away are
you worried about governments having
your data or companies a little bit of
both i guess governments politicians
have to use social media in order to
communicate with everybody
[Music]
we should have more women in politics
climate change is real so something
should be done you pay taxes on bikes
but not on flights i use the public
transporter just cycling representative
from the cv society but also from the
political sphere and we're going to be
addressing all those issues
the democratic space around the world is
shrinking slavery is back no one is too
big to be regulated
82.4 million people worldwide are
forcibly displaced
the numbers have doubled over the last
decade there's a lost generation my
brother is one of them is eight years
old all he has seen from his life is war
there are millions and millions of
syrians who have again seen nothing but
war nobody likes to leave his country
over 100 million people are already
being pushed into extreme poverty our
job is to make sure that inequality at
birth does not mean a lifetime of
inequality society as a whole has to
take care of those that might be left
behind this cannot be a society for the
few and when we talk about growth it's
also important to ask
what is growing
fortunately no no
we cannot just give this money to the
multinational companies and just to
enrich and increase their profits it's
super hard for the authorities to go
into every cell phone of the world but
it's rather easy to go into apple and
google and then be in every cell phone
in the
this world really the crisis with the
face of a woman we have to increase our
preparedness because this one will not
be the last one make the covet vaccine
available to every person in every
country by the end of 2022.
[Music]
the sign on social media to notify
someone if you're in need is this
the mind has been crossed
it's about women being in solidarity
together and taking men on board as well
to push gender equality women are taking
over the world apart from going to a
couple of black lives matter marches
last year nothing changes we all need to
come together
[Music]
post a tweet and she says we ask the
leaders to take decision but if you ask
you will never get anything you must
connect this to politics let's have a
conversation of grown-ups now let's have
a conversation of equals
there are two concepts of politics the
one is delivering answers on the
questions of our society and the other
one is simply about brutal power we see
the world in a new perspective
my hope and dream for the next 10 years
is that we keep appreciating and
understanding the impact that we have
not as individuals but on one another no
one country can do it alone let's never
give up progressives around the world
face similar challenges this is why the
global progressive forum represents an
extraordinary platform to reach a common
solution to global challenges the dream
is never only a dream it is the first
step into a better future
is
[Music]